hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to such scary 2016
supposedly the scariest game ever made
also it's a horror game also it's a
comedy game Tommy horror something like
that hello it's simple take the rock and
put it on the pedestal use left mouse to
interact with stuff oh and there's an
easter egg in every room is there I
can't see [ __ ] you're talking about this
rock here it's glowing possibly
irradiated rock
I'm sure there's nothing that's gonna go
wrong with this Vlade Lottie freakin
Dottie here we go hey I didn't get these
dragged [ __ ] I'm an idiot
let's see where's the rock hold shift to
run I don't know where's the Easter Egg
is that the rock how do I crouch oh no I
got it anyway oh okay I did it I'm so
happy with myself oh oh no it's under
not under the table this time oh well
then [ __ ] I am boner owned how am I ever
gonna be able to find this rock my only
objective is to put rock on table
pedestal thing what's that Hey
oh is it is that a dick but I see oh
it's the pedestal of
oh okay
sit through this door hello it's a rock
in here and I can't breathe
oh but if it's not here then woke a I
see it I got it okay
right then getting a bad feeling about
this but okay I did it
I put rock on pedestal are the greatest
but where's the pedestal ah [ __ ]
well ah here
gee getting a little more sinister whoa
wait a minute whoa wait a minute hang on
a second here gonna oh oh you're gonna
be like that are you oh you're gonna be
like that anything behind the door
Easter eggs I have no idea where they
are
I don't have to go back Oh God hello you
didn't forget the stuff did you now no
oh why would I have hey there's a
pedestal over there but I just know okay
where's all the Easter eggs alright this
guy go for it huh
gonna put this dragon egg down here I
did I did this thing okay which way is
it
Oh that way he's down there okay uh
hello [ __ ]
oh you're gonna be like this oh god no
oh no my open both of them I'll be able
to defeat the system in here yeah no
that was a lie [ __ ] hello
well these are awfully dark nobody in
here huh is that Dwayne the rock Johnson
huh I don't think that's saying I'm
looking for is not throw there's not the
rock why did I say egg
cuz I'm an idiot all right Oh pray
[ __ ] shadows press button at your own
risk
okay did something happen to the rock
rocky oh god is he okay
oh good he's okay okay so ah that's good
perfect
okay thank you thanks for the rock hand
shadows key okay I did that only seven
more rooms to go a very important list
tree fire turtle truckful Mingo Fox fish
trap I'm not gonna remember any of that
I'm not gonna remember any of that I
don't remember any of that okay
ah so there's buttons here so if I were
to guess what this meant I would have to
think that these are in order of
something and I'm beginning to think it
might be alphabetical order so if I
correspond these to the buttons on the
thing but I push them in alphabetical
order so fire would be the first one and
it's the second one so point okay that
makes sense then flamingo which would be
this the fifth one then no ah nope okay
so fire fish flamingo Fox
heck yes
okay then tree truck turtle traps so
trap would be first trap tree walking
did that do something I thought it did
something something was happening ah
something happened dang it what if I do
the other ones trap free ah woo I did it
okay I just had a doom bolt separately
oh yeah what's that hey it's a creeper
if you see Gordon Freeman give him this
okay
half-life okay I get it uh-huh get my
egg now go over here I did it I did it
I don't know what the Easter egg in the
first one would have been okay just go
for it if it doesn't work turn around
and see where that gets you oh that did
that doesn't sound good
oh that doesn't sound good at all oh I
don't like the sound of that
huh huh huh huh
oh just turn around see what I can see
okay
I'm going for it oh I like this room
well I don't think Oh is something
happening whoa I made it I think did I
make it
oh good it worked last time what could
go wrong kibou me okay hello ah pedestal
but where is egg here is egg where is
Easter egg okay
I don't know oh there was a button ah
okay hang on I need to go back and I
need to get the Easter eggs in these
things because otherwise I'm going to
hate myself before I get to the end so
I'm going to get these rigs so there's
an easter egg in every room so you say
but I can't see what's in this room I
can't see nothing at all oh hello see
where is your body oh good question I
didn't even ask myself that I don't have
a body I usually don't question when I'm
playing first-person shooter games
first-person games not shooting anything
very strange they're strands okay I need
the one in room two hold shift you run
where is loop C jet fuel can't melt
steel beams oh my god okay so I think I
got the one in room three so I need room
for
okay ah what happens if I close this and
then open it up again nothing nothing at
all ooh I forgot my stuff
I forgot the stuff I forgot the stuff
put that there
that's good oh oh oh found it found it
found it found it what I find oh who is
that who is that I don't know who that
is
oh that's the creator okay no wonder I
don't know who that is
ah it's nobody all righty then
okay so now that I'm caught up oh no I'm
not cut off I need to get it room seven
how did I not get one from her rip seven
oh I thought I did this oh yeah this is
the one then then and then I'll be
caught up let's go ah drop that there
for now and then huh boom sonic sanic
okay bye sanic have a good day hmm all
right roommate now we're getting into
the new territory five digits got him
right here baby
okay five digits how am I supposed to
know be able to know what they are was
that what was that what was it something
happened somebody happened over here huh
alrighty then
okay oh all the cakes not a lie
oh well apparently that is a lie but not
for me that Easter egg was not well
hidden
okay so pi is the pot pie okay so it
probably wants the first five digits of
pi 3.14159265
what's nope 3.1415
yay I did it
whoa okay anything else here anything
else here all right okay good good good
good good good I'm doing it like I
should hey remember those old cell phone
keypads knotted wool nordhal uh-huh
uh-huh ah okay I get it that's for
reference which I don't need because I'm
a smartypants okay what am I supposed to
do with this is this gonna kill me is
the ring girl gonna come out hello
anybody okay so I'm assuming if I open
this is gonna be a little bit different
out there is that different I can't tell
there anything else in here okay found a
Bree V don't know why I needed a
breather but got it so oh I get it it's
it's a VHS which means that I need to
put in the numbers for V H and s eight
47.0 and I already got the Easter eggs
I'm good to go
didn't get double Easter egg nope okay
we're almost to the end wait three more
rooms to go just like room seven but
nothing like room seven okay fine then
okay sooo how is it not like a room
seven what are you doing stop breathing
on me maybe I don't need to turn back
maybe I just need to keep plowing
forward maybe that's the only way to get
anywhere around here nope hello Oh lots
of numbers see where do you live
well that's awfully personal question I
don't think I want to answer that okay
where do I live does it mean
doesn't mean where do I live get another
clue
because I don't know how to answer them
there's nothing in here are you fine you
oh stop breathing on my neck
okay so 1025 that's easy so I just need
to put one at ten and there Wow
something splode how did something
splode so ah this did splode so in here
ah there's the egg ooh okay so what I
don't have and how am I gonna be able to
juggle both of these okay I don't have
the pedestal and I don't have the Easter
egg so I need to do something about that
go to juggle okay so it's gotta be the
it's got to be the puzzle of where do
you live
oh no oh no what's going on here
oh no oh no oh no oh oh oh pixelated
pickaxe but I didn't even answer the one
about where I live well that's got to be
the one that leads to the pedestal then
but I don't know how to answer that in a
sequence of buttons oh here we go
oh we're back okay alright so it's got
to be through here so I got to just
solve this where you live
I don't know I don't know why that was
the one but it was how I can't see got
anything course I can't I don't know why
that one was the one but okay I'll take
it okay and then probably in this room
they looked empty yes sir
yessiree boom okay but there's a note on
the table isn't there yeah okay last one
I promise okay sure whatever you say but
I don't know where this blue where the
hell did this go boom not down there did
it no that's where the last one blew up
so it's got to be done this way Roy it's
cool to be it's good to be oh god no it
wasn't oh jesus okay I'm just gonna do
this blind doing this blind I don't even
know if I'm going straight fed you're
nutters okay fine uh-oh
what oh come on I wasn't trying to cycle
back oh try to get the anger oh god damn
you damn you damn you I'm not gonna go
back we go I don't know where I am
Oh God what's that oh I see it it's
right there there we go god damn it I
got through this ah I'm willing to bet
that if I would have uh I'm willing to
bet I wouldn't let in it was like right
next to the oh you might need Wikipedia
for this one well no I'm not gonna look
up Wikipedia I'm gonna know this with my
brain no okay uh the date that they
landed on the moon was that whoops yeah
it was 1969 hell yeah I know my space
stuff I know it oh boy it's gonna be a
series of puzzles the answer is faster
than light so
nothing I can solve it with my brain
okay so what's faster-than-light
technically nothing nothing is supposed
to be faster than light but I tried zero
so it's got to be actually something if
it's the number of the speed of light I
don't know that so I'm going to look
that up okay so the speed of light in
meters per second is 299 792 four five
eight meters per second so I'm gonna do
one more than that
not hey okay got it
I didn't know the actual speed of light
off the top of my head how would I have
known that loser another Easter egg in
here bunnies Easter Egg Oh scuse me I
don't know why but at least I got it and
there's only one Easter egg left to go
so now habu ski yeah I did it last room
okay you got this far this should be
easy right yeah you think so one would
think one would suspect Oh No but I
can't crouch Oh God
Oh No how do i Oh Lord oh good golly
gosh how do I crouch
how do I do this Hey yeah I can't lift
it well this is a conundrum okay I'm
gonna turn my back I'm gonna go this way
good dude let's go through the wall
which is awfully nice and convenient of
it but I don't problem is I don't go
through walls I can't jump I can't huh
ain't dis apostle so I can't extend
things in my grip these walls not really
walls I walked through one of these
walls or they transparent not that one
nope can I can't click on any of these
oh hey whoa hey put it back that's
[ __ ] I threw it I threw that dang
thing I threw it good yeah okay well
thank you mysterious force that likes to
do that
if I can just angle it better maybe I
can get it right on the thing and that
is gonna be good
yeah also close a little higher
yeah dang it I can't do higher yeah I
can do higher I can do this
yeah oh that one was a close one yeah
[ __ ] okay yeah I did it hell yeah but I
didn't get these dragged [ __ ]
other than I don't know I need that I
need that sweet Easter egg I need it so
the the answer must be throwing
something else over there yeah whoop no
that doesn't come back
yeah hey ah [ __ ]
yeah oh that one should have made it huh
damn it damn it oh that was a [ __ ]
throw yeah I can't see now so I don't
have any judge of how far wind up I am
oh [ __ ] off [ __ ] ah [ __ ] [ __ ] huh
come on ah [ __ ] never gonna be able to
get this maybe from the other side yeah
nope yeah no damn it oh god damn it
yeah duh yeah
ah there we go got it nailed it okay I
did it and I got all the Easter eggs
that wasn't scary at all ha ha ha so
it's one of those situations where I see
a game online and it's very highly rated
but it's got a silly name and a silly
concept it was pretty interesting I I
can't exactly say it was a great game
but to be perfectly honest Oh shadows
could have been on high brightness could
have been up oh that would have made my
life so much easier oh my goodness I
could have been playing an extreme
graphical fidelity oh that would have
been much better oh it's lovely here ok
so anyway that is such scary 2016 so
thank you everybody so much for watching
hope you enjoy this video I had some fun
with this one so thank you again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]